♪ (DRAMATIC STRING MUSIC
PLAYS) ♪
LOGAN ROY: It's war time.
To fight this takeover,
we keep close.
The whole family.
I swear to God, Dad,
if you bring him back,
I am walking.
...back to my office to--
sol-- Fuck!
What the fuck is going on
between you and Dad?
-Why is he protecting you?
-I just can't say.
It's time to bring you in.
How do we know
he's not a double agent?
It's possible.
ROMAN ROY:
Should we frisk him for a wire?
Burn him? See if he's a witch?
Times have changed.
There are no rules.
This is kind of
against my principles.
Your principles?
Greg, don't be an asshole,
you don't have principles.
I'm surrounded by snakes!
And fucking morons!
Here's a newsflash.
I...
am gonna win.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪